boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
behavior design and gamma fication we
have youkai Chow joining us on the show
hello hello great to be here thanks for
coming on brother really appreciate er
yeah we have so much to talk about you
Kai's background is awesome you Chi is
the original creator of that talus
framework a gamma fication pioneer
behavioral designer and author / keynote
speaker he's president of the italian
founder of attalos prime which is a
gamified mentorship platform his work
has empowered over 1 billion users
experiences across the world and his
thirst this is his most recent book
actionable gamma fication which you can
check out below we'll be talking about
this quite a bit throughout the
conversation today all right ok let's
start things off with this big history
perspective on civilization we find
ourselves as stewards of earth what is
your current take on the state of
humanity ok so I think for most of human
history a lot of things that are just
about survival none it's about thriving
you know the times are hard diseases and
we're getting to a place where I think
in the last few decades it's about an
enabling technology technology that
brings us you know more capabilities so
then you have the hardware wave and the
stock well now we're coming to a very
interesting space because now we see Oh
while there's technologies our software
we can interact with with technology but
we're not happier right our brains
aren't more delighted and so now we're
getting to places ok why what can make
us happier what can give us more meaning
and this is why you see this wave you
know it's insane mystical where the
technology wave is now people are
talking about mindfulness right
spirituality about human focus design
about how do you add more meaning and in
purpose about you know starting with why
all that stuff is what we start to crave
for because once we satisfy those
survival needs and these functional
needs now we want to have inspirational
needs and I think we're getting to that
world where just because you have great
technology and features and technology
and all just the stuff like
it's not enough for us we need to figure
out what empowers the human spirit and
connects people together and they feel
less lonely less depressed so I think
that's where we're at where we're at a
place where the brain matters a lot and
feelings matter a lot so so you know a
lot of people like what I do and some
other people is now really just focus on
okay how do you empower humans not just
products and features and technology
yeah you you make it clear that a lot of
the millions of years of evolution that
goddess said this point of this
technology explosion was and will show a
graphic with this is just the more of
the bottom primordial needs of Maslow's
hierarchy and now a majority of what we
crave with the explosion of technology
is meaning purpose fulfillment
self-actualization and transcendence and
so you've created really a framework
that gives that brings us all to light
for people and well let's we'll be
unpacking that in a bit youkai let's ask
you about your journey and how you got
to this point you're born in Taiwan and
spend some time in South Africa and then
you move back to Taiwan and then Kansas
then Los Angeles and you picked up you
started a couple companies and like
really got into gaming a lot and then
figuring out some of these tactics and
now you built yourself up so here tell
us about this well I wasn't gaming
before beforehand and I got into the
gamification when I started my company
so my father is a diplomat from Taiwan
so we would move a lot like he said to
different countries as in South Africa
from two years old to eight years old
and my life experience was space I get
there an environment I don't speak the
language very well behind in school and
socially awkward and then I just try to
work hard to catch up to people learn I
observe how people feel and you know how
to gain some respect so I start to catch
up in the fight and then once I feel
like yeah I figured this out and
thriving me then I get there an
environment where I completely suck
again and I start all over and I think
that allows me to
to have his presence to have this
empathy these are all skills that I
later on harness like substantially I
have a worldview about okay because if
you grew up in one culture you'll think
oh this how the world works as our
society works as how humans are you
can't change it but when you go to
another country another culture like wow
like things that were considered polite
and correct in one country is offensive
year yes so then you start seeing things
from multiple angles and more ripple
worldviews that's crucial yeah
absolutely there's all there's all these
hilarious stories that I have that you
just I just got penalized greatly and
people don't like me and that's the way
you're interacting with kids in Taiwan
versatile you interact with kids in
South Africa versus in Kansas yeah
completely different yeah you know
teachers don't like me yeah so because
the way I like what what's considered
good behaving student in one place would
be drastically different another place
they're very important things to be able
to pass along to others that may not
have left their own cultures yeah and so
the importance of leaving your own
culture is to is very important yeah
yeah yeah okay here's one interesting
example people these they talk about the
I don't have heard about the China
Social Credit System yeah Osumi credits
ya system you credit they look they're
they basically have a FICO score on
being a good citizen
right in terms of just going to just
researching patriotic things buying
Chinese product as opposed to foreign
products and even the friends you make
will affect your score and from the
Western culture to look at that and like
wow that's like censorship that's like
complete dictatorship and tyrannical
control but when you look in the culture
in China they don't mind but most of
them don't mind that they think this is
really good I've had friends who say we
you know in the u.s. there's no there's
no cameras everywhere I feel less safe
in China everywhere there's a camera so
you know their safety like the
government's watching if people are
committing crime and they feel good
about at that so so in China in the
Chinese culture the Chinese culture is
that you you generally believe in your
leader and you follow the leader and you
do your part well right and
interesting yeah and of course the
leader proves to be too tyrannical
sometimes in history they'll overthrow
the dynasty and whatnot but generally
you listen to the Emperor you listen to
and they threw in the historically they
believe Emperor's are installed by by
this heavenly divinity it's like this
temper and there's the golden dragon
then and that's in his blood right so so
in that culture they don't mind that as
long as they believe the government is
is okay you know and and law do you
think they're it's okay they think this
helps us have more order in society and
now you know and so then the characters
are playing their roles in the great
game of the development of China towards
prosperity would but with a little bit
more like it's kind of gamified in a
sense with the social credit I mean the
US has its own gamma fication with
capitalism and free markets and The
Improv putting up the individual okay so
it's kind of like different code and
different yes so I'm not saying the
moral implications of it myself I'm just
saying there's a few points out but I
think one way to understand it better
from our Western views think about you
have a dad and that's really strict he
has all these systems and rules it
doesn't like you do this and he monitors
that and but we we believe that our dad
loves us and is good for us right so we
taught we think okay I get system is
fine you know he's making us study
harder to get in college whatever yeah
you know he's teaching us hard lessons
in life so because we we trust our dads
most of us and when there's a harder
system we don't mind it so but we think
oh government shouldn't shouldn't have
that kind of type of power here all
right but in China a lot of people
believe government is the same thing you
know when there's more systems there's
more observation of and there's more
power it's a good thing it helps us to
keep society to order like I'm like a
thoughtful mom and dad loving with
guidance and direction towards that
prosperity yeah just sometimes the you
know maybe like younger people or the
individuals could have good ideas that
might not get heard and sure there's
that that's that dynamics all there so
going back to my story as I've grown up
I became a very heavy gamer
and I think the turning point in my life
was 2003 when I was playing this game
called Diablo 2 yeah and I spent
thousands of hours you know getting more
gear leveling of getting gold at just
perfecting all the skills and they got
to a point where all my friends start
putting the game and it moved on to
other games so I quit too and I was in
this transitional period between
quitting and games starting a new game
and I just felt extremely empty I'm like
wow all those thousands of hours I
invested into this game is just gone
yeah like partum like just just
disappeared and so it was very it was it
was the dark depressing feel and I
thought well would it be awesome if I
spent those thousand hours learning
language or playing the violin I would
actually be holla when in the real world
not just in a game and so that led me
into a journey of thinking about - two
topics one is how do you make games
where the more time you spend on it the
more productive your real life is you're
you're successful from a career
standpoint you're healthier you you're
closer to your relationships and also
how to make real life more interesting
and fun because most people think you
know real life it's kind of boring and
mundane just have all these chores you
have to do and maybe watch some TV or
play some games on the side so it's how
do you make that more interesting so
that led me on a journey and at UCLA
where I went to college on my undergrad
I my first in college I started my first
business because I just saw it like a
game it was like really fun you have
your resources you have your goals you
know people define sometimes a game as
just voluntarily tackling unnecessary
obstacles you know sometimes adding
adding blocks and difficulty makes it
fun if it's too easy no one wants to
play the game so so I started a few
business so I started one and led to
another ones that led to another and and
I I never started my companies because I
had this huge vision of you know I want
to be rich or she had this huge because
it was just fun I just enjoyed it it's
like a game and I learned a tremendous
benefit from it it's of course a lot of
tension and stress and I definitely have
more failures than successes yeah but
just like a game you never beat a game
the first time you play it right if you
do that's probably a bad game yeah right
you have to fail many times dies like
okay that's why I died and the next time
I got to stage 3 this time and
oh now I got stage 5 right so it's like
it's like evolution and you grow from
that which could basically be what we're
doing right now sure in our little 80
year game sure that way does he beat
your previous high score yeah yeah yeah
so interesting and I really enjoyed when
you mentioned the period of time in
between games where you came up with
this realization that how can I make
what I've learned applicable in in the
real world and how can I help design
games and gamification and then started
starting the businesses so yeah take us
continuous on them so I'd start a lot of
startup companies and that the term
wasn't defined yet but they're all in
today's terminology all in the
gamification space and you can imagine
that was very very early rights 2005
when I started my first company and you
know nowadays I think most people even
if they heard of gamification they've
heard of it in the past three to five
years right so so 2005 I was the crazy
guy who just had this had this vision
and I just want to do it and I was very
lucky very blessed because you know over
many years organizations companies even
government started to realize how
powerful this could be and so they
looked around and I have to be the only
person who's been doing it for so one of
the only people who has been doing it
for so long and so I started getting a
lot of opportunities now the big turning
point in my life was when I started to
start to gather information about ok
what actually makes a game successful
why are we motive Winston why are there
things that are important in lives that
we know we should do you know working
out eating healthily you know focus on
productive not procrastinating but we
just don't want to do it and then
there's things that are generally not
that useful you know going on Facebook
playing some games it doesn't really
help us real life in most senses but we
just spend sometimes 8 to 12 hours a day
doing that and so I did the study and
then I ended up deriving the stream or
called the oktai Lass's framework yes so
I shared on my blog and it was instantly
picked up so within the years
organically
translated into over 16 18 different
languages and so on twitter at sea like
a conference in Russia and out there and
it's an image on their big screen they
they have my analysis framework there
and I I don't understand all any of the
words but it's like that's not a
callouses framework and so then I
started to be able to lecture some of
that at Stanford University occasionally
I do workshops and talk said you know
Google they go huawei first I do some
advisory for some governments like for
the Singaporean the UK and buck range
whoa yeah so it was just a very very
lucky where I I did something and it
stuck and people really resonated with
it they saw it was really useful and it
grew from there so so then eventually
led to what I'm doing today which is
octal is this group which is a
consulting design company that helps up
other company utilize this this
understanding motivation and engagement
to drive more business metrics and then
there's what I call that something like
Alice's prime which is a education
platform for people to learn about all
the things that I've acquired in my life
there's a game of five fun clap yes yes
where I am today and and you you Chi
also has a four hundred-plus of these
five to ten minute videos explaining
what he's learned in his life so he has
a lot of content and this is part of the
act Alice's Prime yes which is part of
the network of people that you're
teaching what you've learned - and this
is Matt this is growing really quickly I
want to I want to highlight something
else that you said which was you
basically through your life really from
like UCLA until now you really got deep
into the question of why why why why and
the more I realized that the guests that
come out on the show they get to the why
they don't necessarily stay at the
surface level of of spending the time
doing things but they've actually went
into the why am i doing what I'm doing
how can I build like you did a framework
that showed the amount of time that I
spend on Facebook and what that does for
me versus the amount of time that I
spend getting to my goals and what I
care about and how that compounded
actually helps me with my sense of
what's and the the the reason why
that if you just look at what and how
that will give you skills but if you
look at why that gives you wisdom and
insights yeah and wisdom in size tends
to be more applicable throughout your
life yes yes let's let's start breaking
down the actual act alysus framework so
we have eight core drives to start and
then around these eight core drives we
have game design techniques ok so ok
serious so first of all it's called the
our calluses because it's a combination
between octagon and analysis I always
thought it's very intuitive but
sometimes I work with a client for a
year and then they suddenly realize that
it's some kind of happy Epiphany it's a
portmanteau yeah like whoa it's like
that and I want to share too early so
the origin of octave the octal assist
framework is I want to understand why
some games are extremely successful and
some games are not and sometimes they're
just clones or copycats they they look
for most people identical but again
someone is very successful when it's not
so I want us to understand what was the
Delta well what actually made things
successful and I noticed a few things
number one it's not because one game has
these game design elements and the other
doesn't right they're copycats they both
have leveling up Easter eggs they both
have achievement symbols yes but again
one successful one's not I also noticed
it's not because the graphics sometimes
the visually stunning game is a huge
failure and the relatively ugly low low
resolution game like Minecraft or
runescape achieves massive success yeah
so what I end up realizing is that at
the end of the day every successful game
has not what I called eight core drives
of motivation yes so so I so I put it on
an octagon and so in here you'll see the
center those are the eight quarters of
motivate all our behavior and then
outside there's these different game
design techniques as an example list
that can bring out those eight core
drives now this is a pretty busy chart
so usually I like to just focus on the
center so I think there's another image
just you're just on that Center one yes
but the unique thing about those eight
core drives is that every single thing
we do inside or outside of a game is
based
one or more of these eight core drives
which means that if there's none of
these eight core drives there there's
zero motivation no behavior happens you
know people watching this show even
they're watching this because of at
least one of these eight core drives it
could be core drive seven keep on
predicting curiosity you're just curious
yes it could be core drive five social
influence and relatedness a friend
invited shared it to them or they you
know colleague say hey check this out
could be core drive to develop an
accomplishment they actually want to
improve their skill levels and and take
their work to the next level could be
cordial one epic meaning and calling
occasionally some people feel like hey
this is where the world's going is
changing the world I want to be part of
it sometimes there's a scarcity factor
which is oh this this speaker only
appears in this country this show once a
year so i want it i want i would like to
reprioritize my schedule to show up when
I do these internal corporate workshops
a lot of it is based on core Drive a
loss and avoidance which is oh I don't
want to lose my job so I show up and
hopefully eventually it's converted to
other core drives but the key thing is
if these eight core drives are not there
then none of the audience would be
watching you wouldn't be here I wouldn't
be here customers not buying Coker's and
I work nothing happens yes think so
these are all why's the eight core
drives are wise yes and then the we're
gonna we're gonna get here but when
you're when the core drives are more in
this white hat gamification more in this
self-actualization part of the hierarchy
you're gonna get a deeper meaning and
purpose and fulfillment than if it's in
the scarcity avoidance unpredictability
side of things yes so yes so these are
the eight and then there's also the the
extrinsic yeah so the key is that these
are the eight core drives and it's
graphed on a knockdown shape for a
reason the top core drives I call them
white hat motivation core drives so they
make people feel powerful and control
they feel good but there's no sense of
urgency so people need to procrastinate
because they are full and control right
they do it whatever they want the bottom
core drives I call them loss in our
blackhat core drives so if you're always
doing something just to avoid a loss
just because you can't have something or
just because you don't know what's going
to happen next
it's still extremely powerful and motive
in our behavior but in the long run if
that was the only motivation it leaves a
bad taste in our mouths because we feel
like we're not in control and we do want
to drop out and then we have what we
call what I call left brain versus right
brain core drives the left side I call
them left brain core drives which I
always make the disclaimer it doesn't
mean that it's geographically on the
left side of your brain but it's
symbolically represents their logical
brain versus the right brain core drives
that's symbolically represent emotional
brain now what's interesting is the left
brain core drive deals what we call
extrinsic motivation things you do for a
reward purpose or goal but you don't
necessarily enjoy the activity so so
once you obtain the reward you hit your
goals or you get used to the reward you
get stale you stop doing that behavior
the intrinsic motivation is about things
that you enjoy doing to the point that
you're even willing to spend money to
experience and even if you lost all your
progress the next day you would still
want to do this fun thing today because
you just and you just enjoy it and so
when you look at this diamond it's very
interesting the white hat portraits are
the things that we actually want to do
on a day to day basis and if we actually
do it it makes us happy so things like
epic meaning and calling a person of
faith are making difference in the world
changing lives development
accomplishment achieving mastery
improving ourselves empowerment of
creative and feedback which is more
about self expression about creativity
meaningful choices right so if we spend
time doing that makes us happy we just
don't do that we spend most of the time
doing the blackhat stuff so loss and
avoid is out the deadline scarcity
exclusive offers unpredictability of
what's on Game of Thrones what's on
Facebook what's on what's on Instagram
right so we spend all our time doing
that stuff but it doesn't necessarily
make us happier so that's why some
solutions say well how do we get us to
do the white hat things well there's two
ways right number one is to remove the
black hat triggers which means you go to
the mountain you go to the beach you go
to the dojo there's no more black hat
triggers that says oh you know this
offer is gonna end in two hours you
should do it right now right there's no
foam or just you just focus on the white
hat or you add black hat to the white
hat activities to compete and this is
where for instance uh you you hire a gym
trainer to call you a loser for not
working out right it feels bad
but at least but it makes
prioritize it makes you work out and
it'll eventually is to court drive to
develop an accomplishment like oh so you
thank but thank you for pushing me so
hard that I can accomplish things that I
couldn't do on my own right and so those
are the two things now the what's
interesting is then you can look at the
dynamics that even the coroner's right
unpredictability and curiosity that's
core dr7 it's on the right bottom and so
this one is what we call intrinsic of a
black hat so intrinsic as and our brains
enjoy it the black hat we feel we're not
in control so this is like the gambling
core Drive but let's say when you watch
Game of Thrones or some some show you
like it's its core Drive some
particulars and curiosity because our
brains enjoy it but a lot of they're not
in control like we want to go to bed at
11:00 p.m. and then we end up binge
watch until 4:00 a.m. right so and one
interesting example for this is about
the intrinsic natures let's say if you
sit there you press a button for four
hours straight and you're guaranteed a
paycheck that's kind of boring right
that's like a job at a factory most of
it unlike that but if you sit there and
press a button for hours straight and
maybe you'll get a paycheck maybe you
won't maybe you lose money suddenly
that's casino gambling and a lot of
people like that right it doesn't make
any sense the same behavior one you're
guaranteed to pay out the other one
you're most likely gonna lose money
that's how the casinos make so much
money but our brains prefer the latter
because we're literally paying for the
intrinsic enjoyable experience of maybe
oh and maybe I wouldn't maybe I'll win
you're not doing for the extrinsic
reward per se you're doing for the
intrinsic motivation experience and so
people come out of the casino they'll
say hey you Chi I lost 200 bucks but
that was so much fun let's come back
next week right and so it's it's exactly
what called intrinsic blackout we don't
feel the control that's why you have
gambling addiction but we enjoy it this
I'd see why 16 18 languages around the
world have this has been translated I
think it's way more this on year one
yeah this was on your one and so it
makes sense that it gives us the deeper
perspective into the why behind our
behavior and then like you said it's
about designing systems that enable us
to pursue the epic meaning
accomplishment empowerment the things
that give us the self-actualization and
transcendence and
designing things that take us away from
scarcity and avoidance unpredictability
that's this is very very cool I wanna
okay let's continue let's continue by
bringing us to how this relates to the
hierarchy of needs
okay so to lay down some context you
know there's a ton of behavioral models
motivation frameworks out there and if
you go to one of these conferences
you'll listen to your speaker talk about
something that's really intelligent
really amazing but then just like well
there's so many of them right how do
they do how do they even connect each
other you know it's all talking with the
same brain and what should I use when I
go home and work on my project right and
so since it's like I said it's talking
about the same brain so there shouldn't
be all these different dimensions that
can't connect to each other right and so
so what I like to do is I like to use
dr. house for him to look at all these
behavioral frameworks and models and
start putting them in context how does
it fit to doc palaces and so far every
single motivation model I have been able
to do that successfully and so here's
the the massive hierarchy and the reason
why this one is interesting it's
probably the number one most well known
motivation model out there now the
validity is is debated at times but I
think it just has the most ubiquity of
everyone pleasing that and as you
probably know the idea of that Maslow's
hierarchy is that it's that you have
your basic needs on the bottom and once
you satisfy your basic needs then you
work on the higher needs that that makes
you happier so you go from physiological
needs into self-actualization like
you're mentioned right yes so if you
look at a different chart where I match
how these different needs connect to the
eight core drives you can see here that
on the top you have cordials 1 2 3 and
those are the whitehead core drives and
you know epic meaning and calling
development accomplishment empowerment
of crate 7 and feedback in the middle of
the triangle you have courgettes 4 and 5
ownership possession which is about
security and safety and social influence
and relatedness which is about know love
and belonging and at the bottom of the
pyramid we have things like core Drive
six scarcity cortex an unpredicted
in court have a loss and avoidance so
it's almost like you can put an octal
assist octagon on top of this triangle
and just say hey look the top ones are
the white had the bottoms of the black
head and there's a reason for that
this was so cool when you showed me this
yeah yeah so there's a reason for that
it's because the bottom of the masses
hierarchy and and the black hat
motivation is based on motivation from
what we call the reptilian brain the
cocktail Pinay the primitive survival
brain and and this is why again I talked
about black hound motivation makes
people take urgent behaviors but they
don't feel like they're in control and
it's because we feel like we're
hardwired to do these things for
survival right and you know talk about
loss and avoidance you're avoiding
danger unpredictable and curiosity or
Splore new lands scarcity impatience you
are going after scarce resources right
it helps us survive yeah so but if we
spend all our tank all our days doing
that we don't feel good about ourselves
because we feel like animals primitive
animals and so the top of the pyramid
and the white hat core drives deal with
things from the neocortex which are as
well what is the meaning of my life you
know how can I achieve the the best
possible result that I can achieve how
can I get to my full potential how can I
have more self-expression and autonomy
right those are the things where makes
that makes us happy and if we spend more
time doing those things we feel more
human and and so that's why that's how
the oculus primer connects to something
like Nestle's hierarchy this was so
beautiful when you showed this to me and
I it also it speaks to how
interconnected your why the a catalysis
framework is to something as popular as
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and how we
designing the code of civilization and
the frameworks and resource flows to
help get us to meaning accomplishment
empowerment for every single one of us
is one of the most important things that
we can do yeah and some one time a
person asked me if I took the mouse's
hockey as a basis and then designed the
white head like it based on that and and
that's not the case
I literally studied games and I created
the framework and then I realized for
every core Drive there's a lot of sites
of research behind it and research and
and studies so I started
expanding my understanding of it and
then after all of that years later I'm
like hey look you could actually
correlate that to all these other models
and there's ton of them we can do so
that means that you're doing it I think
then in like you said most people have
to go to the most hundreds or thousands
of years old knowledge or wisdom and
build off of that but you built it and
then looked back at the wisdom and said
whoa it overlaps which was a big aha
moment that you're on the right and I
can tell you why studying games end up
being so fruitful it's because if you
think about traditional psychological
experiments it's like you have a class
with let's say 100 undergrad students
and you divide into groups right and
then you let them do some kind of
experiment but with one group there's
one change right and if that second
group of the change behave different
from the first group there's a go that
change actually is changing that
behavior right and they can replicate
that experimental classrooms then it's
scientifically proven to be - to motive
to change behavior now if you look at
games right every single game is like a
petri dish of hundreds of thousands
hundreds of millions of test subjects
yeah all voluntarily changing their
behavior based on the design so you can
say oh we added a bit more
unpredictability it's only everyone
change their behavior we had a bit of
scarcity and then you can look at why
some games people can play forever like
chess you know and it's still fun and
why they're games like Farmville where
people are excited about it for eight
months and then they suddenly like hate
the game they just want to quit and when
quitting the game feels amazing yeah and
so you can start identify all these
patterns so it's a lot based on output
about how what actually comes out of
human behavior in a feature to the
simulated environment and so that the
insights derive from that actually turns
out to be very valid I love the way that
you talk about it like the game becomes
nested it's it's a simulation it's a pit
suit it's a petri dish within our own
petri dish which is civilization or that
one yeah so so figuring out what games
to make
within the game of civilization that
maximize self-actualization self
transcendence meaning and purpose is
important the games that that are taking
us away from the things that we love
away from meaning and purpose get rid of
now you know our brains need those eight
core drives so either we find in the
real world or we find it in the gaming
world right epic meaning but we want to
have more purpose in our lives and so
people who are who feel like they're
changing the world they don't want to
play games there every day they wake up
they don't want to go to bed right they
wake up they're doing it they don't tire
out they just work The Hollies they hate
taking vacations why would they why
would you take away them away from their
favorite game right but then if you
can't find these things then it's like
oh I guess I'll go into a game world
where I'm saving the world they're you
know I'm defeating this demon or this
this this alien species and they find
epic meaning and then this is why we see
so many people that lack meaning in the
real world play games and find epic
meaning in the virtual worlds absolutely
so either civilization updates its code
where we can help all eight billion
people find huge amounts of meaning and
purpose in the real world or we'll lose
4 billion of them or pretend yeah to the
virtual worlds which we kind of see in
some of the books yeah and and so it
doesn't have to be meaning and purpose
itself that's just one of the eight core
drives ideally its Whitehead or
intrinsic so either you let them feel a
lot of space of expressions
self-expression creativity or you let
them feel socially connected people some
people feel underappreciated everywhere
they go so where they going the game
world they feel appreciate it right so
guess what they're gonna go there very
often right I'm predicting curiosity Oh
everyday it's mundane same things same
old same old nothing to anticipate but
in the gaming world there's there's all
these unpredictability curiosity designs
everywhere from loot box
you know Easter eggs new content showing
up and it's just you never know what's
gonna happen next and that again
connects to the almost like the gambling
brain totally you just want to do
yeah so so the NASA hierarchy is a nice
space but then I think what's also
interesting is the the
self-determination theory I think you
have yeah yeah yeah and I and I'm just
so fascinated by the trajectory of
civilization because uh catalysis gives
us a another it adds to our worldview
and if a if a bifurcation based on
socio-economic soar whatever may happen
and we see a ready player one style
scenario of lots of people living in
virtual worlds to find meaning and
fulfillment and the physical world not
being in a state of as much flourishing
as it could potentially be I think that
one of the main reasons why we would
have ventured into that line of the zip
code versus the zip code where all eight
billion people are experiencing
flourishing and we have a utopic style
of civilization on a grand scale
multiplanetary etc is because we just
didn't have enough of time to slow down
we didn't prioritize slowing down to
think about what kind of a long-term
civilization we wanted to build and so
we got it we have to prioritize maximal
flourishing for all beings and
fulfilling the basic physiological needs
for all beings and prioritizing that and
this is a problem when the world's
getting more and more data-driven like
data driven sounds very great it's
sophisticated intelligent it sounds good
the problem is it can come and the thing
is that society isn't controlled by one
entity right it's a it's it's many many
little ecosystems at play with each
other and as these ecosystem get more
data-driven what happens they'll do
things that create immediate results and
the problem is because black had
motivation drives urgency like I
mentioned when your two folks in the
data you're always gonna do more black
hat motivation right you put you put it
what we call a torturer break on which
is those designs that says you have to
wait eight hours before you can you can
move forward unless you pay a dollar or
whatever it's like wow we did this and
then people are paying tons of
they're coming back ten times a day it's
amazing in telling all their friends
about it so let's do more of that let's
put more torture breaks on Ryan and so
society will get more and more blackhat
because the drugs results KPI driven
yeah right
but it doesn't necessarily make us
happier so people burn out and that's
why nowadays we're at the most advanced
civilization in history we were
technology advanced you know on average
you know we're flourishing everyone has
smartphone yes but you know drug abuse
and suicide is right as is higher than
car accidents now so it's hard used to
be the number one in the US and now it's
those two and you can see there's a huge
emotional problem in the society this
flourishing economically this is one of
the main arguments that we have to
Steven Pinker's better angels of our
nature it's just true in so many ways
that we are experiencing the greatest
civilization simultaneously why are
there such high suicides why are there
such high emotional
ale mints that are causing drug abuses
and addictions so I think this is very
ties directly into the catalysis
framework and it's so fascinating
talking to you about it so yes so we
have these three innate psychological
needs that comprise the
self-determination theory of yeah so
this is just another example of looking
at different other models and frameworks
this one is one of the most well known
it's the self-determination created by
Ryan and de Chi Europe and it's
popularized by Daniel pink and the book
is called drive drive and he adds so so
in the self-determination theory it
talks about Oh surprise humans aren't
just motivated by getting a reward and
avoiding pain they are motivated by
these three intrinsic motivation factors
which is competence
it's a relatedness and autonomy Daniel
pink adds purpose to that list yes and
he changed competence to mastery which
sounds cooler in a longer conversation I
argue that it's less precise but if you
if you look at the self-determination
theory and you relate it to the octal
assess framework yes so I think there's
another chart of that yeah yep and this
is again this is kind of finding
yourself in a state of flow you and your
self determined to been motivated to
pursue actualization that's a your
certain level of competency a certain
level of relatedness and autonomy that
you have with what you're doing and then
yes oh here it is related to the so if
you look at the causes framework purpose
is obviously connect to epic minion
Colleen quarter at one competence or
mastery is tied to develop an
accomplishment autonomy is connected
Powerman of creating a feedback which my
definition was about you know
self-expression autonomy meaningful
choices and relatedness obviously is
connected to social influence and
relatedness and so you can see that the
self-determination theory covers all
these white hat core drives right it's
on the top of the octagon so it's very
very good there but it doesn't
necessarily for instance explain why
people are addicted gambling yes you
know it doesn't talk more a lot about
the black hat motivation core Drive
scarcity that creates obsessive behavior
and I think it doesn't have to you
because the goal of the
self-determination theory is to get
people to do creative work in the law
for the long term and we know that white
hat motivation
is great for that getting people be
creative work sustainably whereas black
hat is about the short-term transactions
like you want to get people to to give
your give you their credit card or like
a two-week competition but doesn't make
people feel good where if you look at
behavioral economics for instance Daniel
Kahneman's Thinking Fast and Slow yeah a
lot of us are on the left left bottom
it's about ownership which is a
endowment effect it's about how to deal
with scarcity how to deal with risk and
avoidance right and so so that's on the
left bottom because it's behavioral
economics it's dealing with extrinsic
stuff right it's and it's dealing with
with a black hat stuff but it doesn't
really talk about why people die for a
higher meaning and purpose yeah right it
doesn't talk about people do things just
to be creative because it's not
economical just to be creative so you so
what this firm you can just start to
look at people's work and understand
okay we're in the spectrum of motivation
is this piece of work more focused on
and you can develop your knowledge there
but also understand the context of it
yeah yep and like you said it's it's so
important to be able to overlay how
certain frameworks have a proclivity to
talk about self-actualization and
transcendence but how a catalysis is
able to have the why for that and the
why for some of the black hats that
happen across the world
okay so within act alysus prime you have
this is what we're you have 400 videos 5
to 10 minute videos people can join a
catalysis prime that's on the link below
with the mucus ow dot-com and can you
give us an explanation of this beautiful
graphic that you have here ok so the
motivation for me to start rock
Palestine was was many fold number one
is I was a little frustrated with you
know we are doing all this great work
for companies and government and a lot
of our projects are you know over a
hundred thousand dollars and obviously
we're helping big companies make real
money but my passions really helped
everyone live through my experience
learn things I and of course that's
obviously an price out of their range
right so I wanted something
that people can learn more so that's
that's the that's the first we did more
of a b2c type of model the second thing
is I one of the first resided also is I
would design these solutions for
companies and I think it's amazing but
they always what the end up creating is
like twenty thirty percent of what I
designed interesting and as a creative
person and we talk about core
drive-throughs empowerment of creating
feedback right when you design something
creative you really want to see how well
it works you want to see flow like magic
makes you happy and so I wanted
something that I had full control over
like I want to show like this is how a
great education platform could be like
and the challenge there is how do you
make it less linear you know most
education platforms are oh you do this
ten modules and you get achievement a
certificate or badge and you this time
so a thousand people would be doing the
same thing and they take all the same
actions there's no meaningful choice
there's no strategy so my question is
how to add core dr3 empowerment of
creative feedback into this so people
can choose a journey they're growing
differently they're unlocking different
power-ups you can strategize literally
three weeks ago one of my hoping members
created a strategy guide on YouTube
about how he chooses to grow in this
journey what he feels it's the most ops
great yeah so when people create
strategy guide huge on an experience you
know there's meaningful choices right
yeah yeah because that strategy guide
was a major part of the gamer culture as
well you would get strategy guides that
be released on how to best play the game
of civilizations yeah yeah that's this
is the best way to play Opie yeah so you
know it's not linear when there's when
people can do that the other thing is a
lot of people reach out and say hey you
have read shoot book like multiple times
I've watched all your online videos a
yachtie where did it go from here right
and I mentioned to you earlier that the
book which is already 500 pages it only
has about 15% of the knowledge base that
I thought I can share yes and so my goal
is okay this is where the journey
continues right yes yes we assume that
people are on the island of course
there's all this basic content too but a
lot of them will already have the basic
content and it's about pushing that to
the next level level two level three
octal is applying to you your your
happiness your career your well-being
relationships and just everything that I
I've learned in my life
and I want to pass down to my twin
daughters you know I want it to be
unoaked Alice's Prime and then finally
another goal for our Tallis Prime is
when I work with companies I feel like
I'm using the same body of knowledge
that I already have and apply in
different scenarios which is really fun
and interesting but I feel like I have
less bandwidth and time to expand that
knowledge base to begin with and with
our calluses Prime what's nice is it
allows me to continuously research more
things research game read books
scientific journals expand a knowledge
base and then continuously share my
late-night latest research and insights
to to the members so now there's a
ecosystem for me to you just learn which
is intrinsically motivating to me so
this was formed so the ik Tallis's group
is where you're doing a lot of the
consulting and so you took the framework
the Casas framework and you started
doing consulting for companies that
would pay for you to help them
understand the white hat black hat
extrinsic intrinsic all these eight core
pillars of wise and then you also
realize that you put about 15% of the of
the data into this actionable
gamification book and then said I also
want a platform so that's up tosses
prime where you can have people come in
individually not at the hundred K level
of corporations but at a smaller level
where they can learn up like 50% of your
content base yeah I'm paying a monthly
to get access but the goal the goal is
to get to 100% of my novel goal is to
get 200 yeah right but yes but that base
is still growing - yeah and like you
said it's a you enter in as your
individual character into the act ocess
prime where you get to pick and this is
is this then part of this graph yeah
yeah and where this is where you're
playing so this way you learn the
material thing and so the center place
the sacct alysus the center is what
you've been describing to us throughout
the show so far these eight pillars yes
and then everything that you see around
the act alysus are things that people
get to pick together so this is kind of
like what I mentioned if you can vaguely
see that the island is based on an
octagon shape
yeah so you know we there's different
content switch things about persuasive
technology which are things you know
created by BJ Fogg yes and his and the
offshoots in the near aisles work and
hook and a lot of people yes and that's
a school of thought then you have
behavioral economics that's on the left
bottom extrinsic more black hat so
that's Daniel Kahneman's thinking fast
fellow that's Richard Patos nudge you
know that's also growing legs you have
applied psychology which are things like
Robert shale Dinis work on influence and
also Oren Klaff where he talks about how
it uses behavioral psychology to to
fundraise right so there's and there's
gameful design which is you know people
who like Jane McGonigal talk about how
game can empower the world make it fun
make it engaging so these are all
disciplines that complete this this body
of knowledge and of course the top
there's what we call a motivation
psychology so that's mckay
csikszentmihalyi Oh theory it's a
self-determination we mentioned so so
all that stuff adds together to a
picture of understanding how the mind
works and how do we and inside the
houses core is how do you apply it again
to your well-being relationships career
to your happiness and finding your
purpose so and understanding those eight
core drives and then we have all these
little mechanics in it to where I have
weekly office hours I spend an hour
answering member questions helping them
design or helping them change to improve
their designs there's a slack community
that people are helping each other a lot
on there's challenges there's daily
chess where they get chow coins and they
can do all these interesting things with
it yeah oh yeah so so what what inspires
me is there's a lot of high school
teachers on this platform and so the
platform is $50 a month there's actually
a powerup and core driving loss and
avoidance that deduct it's that it turns
into you $30 because you don't want you
want to avoid paying bills so like every
core Drive has multiple power-ups
depending on what you're learning
students is a $20 month so it's it's
it's not like ten dollars like like
Netflix but it's it's but it's not it's
much cheaper than a college education
right so my comparison is that it's like
a gym membership it is which also means
that you don't pay them
you transform lives right you pay the
money then you put in the time you're
engaged with it that's right and then I
we've seen lots of members you know
they've raised their funding to raise
money for the startups through it yeah a
guy was a music teacher and then he
became a interactive game designer for a
music education company so it's like his
dream job yeah so so we do see
transformation through this and and so
it's just it just makes me happy to see
all this stuff happen and it's my it's
again it's it's the project I want to
leave for my daughters
my friend was saying if he gets hit by a
bus he wouldn't be able to pass down his
wisdom knowledge to his young daughter
and I thought it doesn't know I might be
actually uh I'm safe there because
everything I want I feel like it's worth
learning in my life I'm putting on our
Towson prime I found way of thinking is
that what have you learned in your life
that is such value of such great value
that you would want to build a really
robust way of disseminating that for
future generations especially your
family your community that's a very
important thing to laugh behind in life
and I'm glad that you've you know I
truly believe in this stuff like Mike
twin daughters Symphony and harmony
there are only 16 months old starting
from 6 months alive I'm already exposing
noctus framework to them getting to be
familiar that of course they don't
understand but they're building what we
call the emotional associations with a
cognitive ease with it because I believe
sincerely like even in my own life if I
learn dr. house or discover doctors
memory even a year prior to what I did
absolutely I believe might life will be
totally different I use this knowledge
on an hourly basis like it's amazing and
it I can I can't even fathom my
daughter's being our Tallis's framework
natives like knowing it and one-year-old
like like how how they live their lives
and how powerful they can be in driving
and then the next thing is how do you
install the right valleys right you're
using this for good from meaningful
things not just to be successful
yourself or for things that harm society
right so so you've got the skills the
abilities but then the values is like I
have a whole video series on our house
about how to teach them Prince my family
pride and values right oh it's like you
should do this because you're a Chow so
even they say oh how come how come Bobby
doesn't have to do that well because
it's not a child you're a child which
means you always do the right thing you
know it's just like you know Game of
Thrones you're a stark right you're a
Lannister it has that type of motivation
is a little bit of epic meaning and
calling your family lineage and your
your values and it and it sometimes they
don't like to think about or they argue
against when they're younger but it
sticks with them throughout life yeah
one of my favorite examples in is in a
Smallville lexer right which is
Superman's chief rival his dad always
says you're a Luthor looks Luthor so
you're a Luthor and Luthor's aren't
afraid you don't back down for Farrell
he was very harsh on his son his dad was
a successful business guy and so Lex
Luthor was with Trane like I'm a Luthor
so I should have be brave right he hates
his dad but he got that good stall so
imagine how much motivation you have to
be the villain against Superman all
right you have no superpowers at all you
use your brain it's like no there's
Superman hanging around but I want to be
a villain I want to be the rival you
need a lot of motivation there and so
for good for bad family valleys of pride
passes down and that's cold I get
quarter up on a bikini and colleague it
would be so interesting to see young
kids even as early as yet three four
years old in these pre schools and
kindergartens doing things like talking
about scarcity mindset versus abundance
mindset self-actualization mindset like
what are you finding most interesting
these are very powerful frameworks to
give to kids I want because this this
these the process of how to actually
implement this into people's lives and
implement it into corporations and stuff
is very important that you have this
this process player desired actions
feedback stats business metrics win
state modes incentives yeah all these
things are applicable so some people
learn the framework and like okay I know
how the brain works but how do I
actually apply this to my project and
when we talk about how you know we have
design projects that's you know over a
hundred thousand dollars we have a
five-step process and the first step is
doing this what we defined
called a strategy dashboard it's
defining a few components of lead to new
ones you know business metrics what
you're trying to improve your players
who your tart targeting the desire to
actually each step you want them to do
each desired action leads to win state
you got FEMA mechanics that trigger
desired actions and and people use a
track progress towards the Wednesday and
these are rewards and it stems that are
bended instead of Wednesday anything is
Wednesday so that's step one and what's
interesting is you know once you do all
five steps that's a robust product we
teach every single step in detail in
octal assess prime yeah so we're not
holding back anything it's like
literally what we teach our consultant
we teach La Crosse's prime and actually
we've hired a lot of accountants group
consultants through octal assess prime
so so the joke is that houses prime to
education platform is a feeder for my
consultant company yeah and is literally
just because you know this stuff is deep
enough I don't like people havin trying
to learn it for five years and they
they're just like okay I've compared to
what I think she excellent I don't mind
people getting exposed to all this
because I know they're not just gonna
the study it for two days and suddenly
you know make a whole whole whole living
just based on that two day amount of
companies that you guys have helped is
crazy that those are very very prominent
organizations and it's good that they're
starting to have a solid understanding
of what is though the whys yes what's
unique is that these companies are a lot
of their health care insurance and
banking finance education and so the the
sweet spot of gamification are things
that are extremely extremely important
but potentially mundane and boring so I
don't work with that many gaming
companies usually if my friend has a
gaming company he wants me be advisor I
say yes but I tend not do it because my
passion is not to create better fantasy
worlds people can escape to my passion
is to make this world so much more
interesting that you don't have to go
there that's right and and so one of our
projects is we work with the largest
steel manufacturer in the world and you
know our project is to reduce injuries
so it's to making safety behavior more
fun and exciting it's to make reporting
and removing hazards interesting
exciting yeah we recently launched the
the loyalty program for Porsche and in
Austria Wow
so it's like you drive with with your
Porsche and then you can earn different
rewards based on your driving behavior
and it also allows you to upgrade to
your next car in the Volkswagen family
in Porsche more easy in your at your
TEDx talk you also gave the example of
of where there's people that are making
it so that the little speed readers on
on interstates are if you're driving
within the speed limit you get entered
into the lottery where you can get a
chance to win them proceeds from people
that are driving over the speed limit
and get fined so it's there's all these
interesting waste to gamify our world
and it's also cool that like you said
it's even down to the steel mill how do
you actually make it more safe for
people to be there you're literally
reducing the amount of injuries and
therefore increasing the amount of you
know families that can stay together and
these types of things it's not
quantifiable but I'm a hundred percent
sure than my work has saved lives in the
past it's hard to measure because you
don't know the lives that would have
would have been lost without without
that environment right yes but better
you know then just the thought of that
we had because we work with insurance
companies they work with companies that
motivate people to drive safer or work
safer in the factory we work a lot of
Health Care well-being type of companies
and so you know those those projects are
really what makes me because I have this
certain skill set that I've concluded
that it's very powerful and useful and
and a lot of my projects are to help big
companies grow grow bigger but then some
company some projects are really just
helped like to talk about getting foster
kids to build a build up their
self-esteem to get people to with
diabetes to to have better behavior to
save the Amazon rainforest
so all these projects are just really
inspiring to me and and I I literally
have so much respect for people who just
work on that right they did I hit their
whole lives to just work on that where
I'm just like hey that's a nice project
yeah I did some impact I'm happy I'm
proud of myself right but I have full
respect for people just like who
consumed their life just
than one mission to to make you man me
better yes yes and you're bringing up
one of the most important examples of
how an acht alysus framework embedded
into healthcare is extremely powerful to
get people living healthier happier
lives and that's an immediate reward
there's an immediate feedback to the
decisions that we make with exercise and
nutrition and sleep that's immediate
feedback and then that also gives a
long-term healthier life as well and I'm
glad it being implemented they're so
crucial
on the way out UK we have to talk about
seeing our world as a game and seeing
our world as code we talked about this a
little bit earlier with um with
civilization acting like an experiment
in a petri dish and then embedding other
games within the petri dish and seeing
how those evolved what would you say are
some of the most important lines of code
to augment within civilization in order
to maximize the amount of actualization
and transcendence that occurs well it
depends on who's the court because
there's from individual standpoint you
can change your mentality to see life as
a game that was my big epiphany yes and
it's not only thrive but everything I
did there's the government that can do
things that can change Tomatoes does any
more gameful there's company over me so
there's educators so it depends on what
angle you're coming in from give us a
bit from all of those if you can okay
yeah yeah so from an individual
standpoint is to see life really as a
game because the thing about a game is
that the game is about you have your
goals you have your current resources
yes and you have obstacles right and the
idea of the game is to figure out how to
use your con resources to get through
those obstacles and reach the goal yes
that's actually much closer to our work
in a real life's right most of our work
is not like what we study in school
which is memorize a bunch of stuff and
regurgitate it onto a piece of paper
right which is why actually playing
games does help you have better
problem-solving skills all these things
so but when we see this in this
framework imagine a game where you just
just go straight forward forward forward
for to four forward and you win that's
that's like stupid book stupid and
boring right gotta be off I have every
bad guy off
game is a chance for us to be awesome
and get more points and win right learn
so in Latin in a real life we should
have that mentality no a lot of people
have this victim mentality they're just
like oh why is just obstacle why is this
bad guy why'd you have an enemy my life
sucks and they go and depression right
and I said no that's your landscape
challenge right you don't complain about
your landscape you forget how to
overcome it yeah right if there's none
of these obstacles then the game's
boring you just kind of live your life
as if nothing happened and you get old
and the game's over all right so so that
mentality is important think about it
from a networking standpoint you know
some people have this this this scary
like comfort bubble right and they're
like oh I don't want to reach out to
people what have they get upset about
it's like well if you look at a game RPG
games you go you walk up to your MPC and
it says what are you doing here get out
of here right you don't feel sad or
upset or anything is like okay and maybe
I'm not high level enough you're gonna
get a certain item right you just like
I'm not qualified yet so let me go do
these other items and maybe I'll come
back to this guy and he'll talk to me
because I'm a higher level personnel
right it's it's it's that mentality that
really changes all this stuff it's going
from like I'm I'm just a victim in life
and all these things I have no control
over to hey I have what Jane McGonigal
calls urgent optimism which is I believe
if I if I try I could reach the
Wednesday but it's urgent I have to do
it now and that is a great type of
psychology in Jaime Garza book
SuperBetter she talks about there's
there's difference between self-efficacy
like hope is believing that there is a
positive outcome and it could happen
optimism is thinking that the positive
outcomes very likely but self-efficacy
is a belief that I effect that positive
offcut I can make it happen right and
self-efficacy is a great psychological
state and I think that is what decreases
depression and whatnot so so you know
when I saw my life as a game I just
drive it everything did before and then
I was I was still a student
I studied just enough to reach my
acceptable grade and I stopped and I and
and I start playing games right but when
you see for your life as a game you're
not just gonna do the minimum you're
gonna do the best you can that's right
right and so my life literally changed
when I saw from as a game and there's so
many different knology so many ways to
you optimize this game this is very
profound what resources do you have now
how do you allocate them to overcoming
the obstacles that are in front of you
in order to level up the most and
achieve this golden goals that you have
these milestones along the way of your
self-actualization and transcendence and
then seeing your landscape that way is
very profound okay and then for another
focus on your journey more than the
result like a lot of people have fond
memories of planes a Super Mario game
and in the original Super Mario game you
know very few like talked up beat the
game but doesn't matter no one's like oh
I don't beat us I'm depressed or I can't
be so I'm not gonna try by playing it
you're winning you're right the only way
to lose they're not play and so that's
another mentality so when you look at
the government you know I think the
government could do things first of all
our work we always have to define what
we're targeting what's the desired
actions and so once the government can
define okay these are the things that
make society better whatever it is right
either it's making people or Shane
andrew yang who's running for 2020
president he says the economy needs to
be measured different way in a different
way shouldn't just be our GDP it should
be about human like if human capital and
thriving right yes flourishing so it's
like well if we know people who do these
things will make society better from a
human humanistic standpoint then it's
about okay how do we add emotional
triggers to that experience how do you
add more meaningful choices that they
and and and self-expression how do we
add more social influence villainous
people feel like they get to collaborate
more they feel more social appreciation
how do we add more in particularly
curiosity so there's new surprising
delightful elements and so you can
create a society with these type of
rules when an example is the Taiwanese
government in the nineteen like I think
1958 they actually gave a fight tax
collection they turn tax collection into
a lottery game and instantly that year
they're like old government tax revenue
increased by 80 percent
what because people were evading evading
taxes and because they made it fun and
people wanted to to play the lottery
game they reported everything I'm more
honestly and then suddenly they doubled
almost doubled their government revenue
so it's other stories yeah so there's
all these type of examples governments
can do educators Yeah right
educators can make learning fun I think
I think that's that's by default where
people feel like oh now it's just
traditional way of again memorizing
things putting a piece of paper it's not
that exciting and coupled with the
students outcome as well just like a
doctor being coupled with the patient's
outcome for sure and so now because
information every online like students
don't lack access to information they
lack access to your coach to guidance
right in context yeah and so the
educators should see themselves as a
friend that allowed the students to
thrive as opposed to a top-down like
like I'm your superior so you listen to
my orders kind of relationship and then
they can make learning a lot so there's
a lot of projects like classcraft
this is a company that I have a lot of
respect for there's a lot of ones that
are just very boring but class craft is
great and so it's just making learning
more fun you know hospitals can I've
I've seen different projects from I know
you and I could talk for so long I want
to also you have mother coming into yeah
we want to pick her up on time and
everything we can UK well we'll do
another show at some point maybe over
the summer where we can get deeper into
a lot of this and inspire other people
to get to view the world view in in this
light and from the Y perspective of the
fatalis framework and it's very profound
hearing you teach about all the
different examples as well we can get
deeper into that too a couple really
quick questions on the way out that we
like to ask our guests on the show do
you think we're alone in the cosmos so I
don't this is something that I don't
have expert I don't know the answer but
from a probability standpoint I think
it's it's likely that there are other if
you're talking alone it's living species
I think it's likely that they're living
species out there and the next question
is do you think we're in a simulation
also no real knowledge of that but and
it depends on how you define simulation
right it's I believe that and I'm
actually a spiritual person so I believe
this world is kind of like a simulation
and and it's almost like when when Our
Lives ends here that's like we stand up
from that computer
and then it's like okay how did you do
in the game did you spend all your time
getting things that don't really get you
points yeah you know like they've been
success on your career or you actually
spend time doing things that actually
accumulate points just being kind to
other people yeah you know and loving
loving others and things like that so
getting on hard yeah so so so I that
viewpoint
you know there's we are in a type of
simulation and and our we're put into
this role you know whatever it's your
gender your race your your origin rights
your role just like in the game you have
a warrior wizard and it's how you play
this role how well you play this role
yeah right but after the game ends none
of that matters you stand up you're just
like a high school game or just like
everyone else who's playing the game
yeah yeah and so that's that's that's my
personal bubble of it yeah
keep leveling up right that's a that's a
really profound way that we like to just
help people with that notion I'm glad
that you have that view and mentality
last question what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
my quick my quick thought about that is
forgiveness I think when someone
forgives something dark and painful I
think it's beautiful
yeah it's good stuff it's a good stuff
you guys it's such a pleasure thank you
so much for coming on to our show it's a
pleasure thank you thank you yeah it's
been such an honor I'm so happy that we
had you on so much profound wisdom came
out of it everyone actionable
gamification the link is below check it
out also check out the links below to
you Kai's website his Twitter his books
and also join up Tallis's Prime if you
want to implement some of what we've
been talking about into your lives and
also get the direct video mentorship of
you Kai and thank you everyone we
greatly appreciate your love and support
watching this episode share your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you also share some of the
italicize Prime lies with your
communities your friends your families
online go and get sharing and talking
about this also support the people that
you believe in the artists the
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that are trying to fulfill
some of these basic physiological needs
and help people with self-actualization
support them simulations links are below
help us grow as well and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you so much thank
you for tuning in and we will see you
soon